welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B with another YouTube short today
we're talking bad batch and assassins
ooh they go together like peanut butter
and blood now episode 7 of the bad batch
the Clone conspiracy introduced us to an
assassin who used a long range almost
similar to Mandalorian gun although it
did seem to have a sniper track maybe
for a second think it was Crosshair but
the voice didn't match anyway we know
Emperor Palpatine had created a clone
assassin unit to help Anakin Skywalker
carry out Order 66 but I'm wondering is
this clone Assassin from that unit or is
this a different even more exclusive
clone assassin unit that we're going to
find out more of that was working under
Rampart that can be hired to kill
specifically other clones I hope bad
batch season 2 will reveal more of that
otherwise I'll have to do some
investigating myself thanks bye